الا الله الله اكبر الله اكبر ولله الحمد
الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا الله الله
اكبر الله اكبر ولله
الحمد
[Silence]
ا
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر الله
اكبر لا اله الا
الله الله اكبر الله اكبر ولله الحمد الله
اكبر كبيرا والحمد لله كثيرا وسبحان الله
بكره
واصيلا لا اله الا الله وحده صدق وعده
ونصر عبده واعز جنده وهزم الاحزاب وحده لا
اله الا الله ولا نعبد الا اياه مخلصين له
الدين ولو كره
الكافرون اللهم صل على سيدنا محمد وعلى ال
سيدنا محمد وعلى اصحاب سيدنا محمد وعلى
انصار سيدنا محمد
وعلى ازواج سيدنا محمد وعلى ذريه سيدنا
محمد وسلم تسليما كثيرا
كثيرا ايها
المسلمون قال الله سبحانه
وتعالى فلما بلغ معه السعي قال قال يا بني
اني ارى في المنام اني
اذبحك فانظر ماذا
ترى قال يا ابتي افعل ما
تؤمر ستجدني ان شاء الله من
الصابرين فلما اسلم وتله
للجبين نادينا ان يا
ابراهيم قد صدقت
الرؤيا انا كذلك نجزي
المحسنين ان هذا لهو
البلاء
العظيم ان هذا لهو البلاء
المبين وفديناه بذبح
عظيم صدق الله
العظيم ايها
المسلمون اليوم يوم عيد
وهو يوم عظيم عند الله تبارك
وتعالى
يوم فدى الله به نبيه اسماعيل عليه
السلام بذبح
عظيم وفديناه بذبح
عظيم عندما اراد ابوه ابراهيم عليه السلام
بذبحه طاعه لله
تعالى كذلك هو يوم
خالد في حياه المسلمين
عامه وحياه نبينا محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
خاصه
ومنه سمي بعيد
الاضحى قال تعالى وفديناه بذبح
عظيم ففي الخامس من شهر ذ
قعده من السنه العاشره
للهجره اعلن اعلن الرسول صلى الله عليه
وسلم عن
عزمه زياره حج بيت الله
الحرام فخرج معه ما يزيد على 100 ال من
المسلمين من الرجال
والنساء وقد استعمل على
المدينه اباد جانه الساعدي
الانصاري
فاحر فاحر للحج ثم لبا
قائلا لبيك اللهم
لبيك لبيك لا شريك لك
لبيك ان الحمد والنعمه لك
والملك لا شريك
لك وبقي صلى الله عليه وسلم ملبيا حتى دخل
مكه
المكرمه وطاف بعدها بالبيت سبعه
اشواط واستلم الحجر الاسود
وقبله وصلى ركعتين عند مقام
ابراهيم وشرب من ماء
زمزم ثم سعى بين الصفا
والمروه وفي الثامن من ذي الحجه توجه الى
منى فبات فيها وفي اليوم التاسع توجه الى
عرفه فصلى فيها الظهر والعصر جمع تقديم في
وقت
الظهر وبعد غروب
الشمس وبعد غروب شمس يوم عرفه نزل الرسول
صلى الله عليه وسلم والمسلمون الى مزدلفه
وصلى المغرب
والعشاء وقد جمع جمع
تاخير ثم نزل الى منى واتم مناسك الحج من
رمي الجمار والنحر
والحلق وطواف
الافاضه وعندما كان
الصحابه رضوان الله تعالى عليهم اجمعين
يسالون الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم عن بعض
اعمال الحج مثل الترتيب بين الرم والحلق
والتحلل
وغيرها لا يجدون منه الا التيسير
عليهم وهو يقول افعلوا ولا
حرج وقد قدم النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم في مكه بعد الانتهاء من مناسك الحج
عشره ايام
ثم عاد الى المدينه
المنوره ايها
المسلمون ذكر اهل
السير ان رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم خطب عده خطب في هذا
الحج اكد فيهن على
التوحيد وحرمه مكه وحرمه
الدماء
والاعراض وتحريم
الزنا وتحريم
الربا واقام
الصلاه واقرار حقوق المراه في
الاسلام ومن ذلك قوله صلى الله عليه
وسلم ان دماءكم
واموالكم حرام
عليكم كحرمه يومكم هذا في شهر
هذا في بلدكم هذا
الا كل شيء من امر الجاهليه تحت قدمي
موضوع وربى الجاهليه
موضوع واول ربا
اضعه ربا العباس بن عبد
المطلب ثم اوصانا
وصيه ايها
الرجال ها هو النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم يكرر في اكثر من
خطبه وصيته
بالنساء فاتقوا الله في
النساء
فانكم اخذتموهن بامانه
الله واستحللتم فروجهن بكلمه
الله ولهن
عليكم رزقهن وكسوتهن بالمعروف
وانكم
لتسالونيكى عليهم اجمعين نشهد انك قد بلغت
واديت
ونصحت فقال باصبعه
السبابه يرفعها الى السماء وينكت الى
الناس اللهم فاشهد
اللهم فاشهد اللهم
فاشهد ثم
قال لا ترجعوا بعدي
كفارا لا ترجعوا بعدي
كفارا يضرب بعضكم رقاب
بعض هذه وصيه النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم من خلال هذه الخطب
الجامعه اشار عليه الصلاه والسلام
الى الكثير من القضايا من القضايا المهمه
كحرمه الدماء كحرمه دماء المسلمين واموال
المسلمين الا
بحقها وهذا يؤكد مبدا راسخا في الاسلام
وهو حرمه اعتداء المسلم على اخيه
المسلم سواء بالقتل او الطعن
او الشتم او الاهانه
وغيرها من الامور المخله بالاداب
الاسلاميه
وتعاليمه واوجز لكم في نقاط
عده من بعض هذه الخطب
اولا حرمه
الرباء وخطوره التعامل به وان اللعنه يصيب
كل كلا من اكله
وشاهده
وكاتبه ومن له علاقه به من قريب او
بعيد
نظرا لاثاره السلبيه على الفرد
والمجتمع
ثانيا ابطال ما كان من عادات قبيحه عند
العرب في الجاهليه ومنها
الثار ثالث
الدعوه
الدعوه الدعوه الى
توقير واحترام
النساء واعطائه
حقوقهن والايصاء
بهن ودعوته
للقيام بما عليهن من
واجبات
رابعا دعوه المسلمين الى ان يتمسكوا في كل
زمان
ومكان بكتاب الله تعالى وسنه رسوله صلى
الله عليه
وسلم
خامسا التاكيد على اخوه المسلمين
ووحدتهم
سادسا حذر
المسلمين من
الاختلاف
والتناحر وعليهم
يعرف ان قيمه
الانسان تقرره تقواه اكرمكم عند الله
اتقاكم وقربه من الله تعالى وليس عنصره
ولا
لونه فجميع الناس
اخوان وابناء لادم عليه السلام
وادم خلق من
تراب فلا عجر
ولا غرور ولا
تعصب ولا تطرف ولا
غلو ايها
المسلمون قال النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم ايها
الناس ان الشيطان قد ييس ان يعبد في ارضكم
هذه
ولكنه رضي ان يطاع فيما سوى ذلك مما
تحقرون من
اعمالكم ماذا يعني النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم لقد وضح لنا ماذا يعني النبي صلى
الله عليه
وسلم عرف الناس ان الشيطان قد طرد شر طرده
بواسطه الاسلام
ومبادئه
ولكن ابواب عودته مفتوحه وهي الاعمال
الباطله التي يمارسها